l'activité est au ralenti sur le site
altit forêt c'est méfie de cosne sur
loire
l'entreprise qui produit des tubes en
acier sans soudure ne réalise plus que
quelques pièces en interne mais aucune
nouvelle commande à l'horizon près de 80
% des ouvriers à l'atelier sont au
chômage partiel certains avec plus de
600 heures depuis le début de l'année
sur place les quelques salariés présents
gardent le silence dans la tente de
précisions parmi eux comme parmi les
élus locaux et régionaux beaucoup se
sentent trompés par la vente du site de
vallourec à haïti fort l'été dernier
vous avez fait pas mal de promesses
rencontre simplement que ces promesses
n'ont jamais été tenues il était
question de diversifier dès le départ
donc ça n'a pas été suivie d'effet il
était question notamment de relancer
l'activité était question aussi de
recruter un commercial leur quelqu'un
qui pouvait générer en tout cas aller
chercher des marchés puis générer de la
production sur le site
à l'évidence donc tout cela n'a pas été
suivi d'effet
depuis le groupe hilti fort qui a échoué
à reprendre la scierie de saint sol dans
le nord a annoncé en avril des
difficultés financières aujourd'hui les
craintes de cessation de paiement sont
grandes
hier la région a réclamé à l'état une
table ronde avec tous les acteurs mais
plus grand monde ne croit encore à
l'avenir du site et des 115 emplois là
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas en tout cas
avec alti fort des perspectives pour la
suite industrielle / sur le site de
colle nous avons sollicité la direction
du site de caunes qui refusent pour le
moment tout commentaire sur la situation
mais bart goias le patron d'al tifour
est attendu ici mercredi prochain si le
contenu des annonces n'est pas encore
connue elle pourrait signifier la fin
des derniers espoirs pour les ouvriers